the show first started to happen i used
to go to the atm and they would say like
maybe you know twelve hundred dollars or
yeah seven hundred fifty dollars in the
checking this is the sitcom yeah before
the sitcom okay and then
i went to the bank of america across
from warner brothers is where i used to
bank and then warner brothers across the
street and and early on after the show
was was on for a little while i went to
the same atm and pulled out some money
and in the and in the balance it said uh
1.7 million dollars
that'll change things bro
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now and use promo code
omghi to get 200
in free bets instantly when you place a
five dollar bet this sunday that's code
omghi only at draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply
see show notes for details
all right you got to hear their new
singing
please welcome to omg high the wolves of
glendale we have ethan edinburgh eric
jakowicz and tom mcgovern yeah thank you
thank you sir which one are you guys
ready jack owens
okay what did they call you what what
what are some of the clever nicknames
here we go children who couldn't do it
they couldn't do it now i just had a
seminar about how to
how to act around a seven-year-old
how did that go
uh
not well yeah no i wasn't a big fan of
that [ __ ] conversation
i'm not a [ __ ] parent
so what were some of the what i know man
i said hey do we plan on having this kid
in the [ __ ] show every week that's
the plan well we have to discuss that
yeah i'm talking about that i think the
audience would miss me he's not around
[ __ ] him
get out of the audience yeah that's our
philosophy too yeah yeah yeah we walked
into everything
we're not in this for the [ __ ]
audience
for the beer
to purge our [ __ ] demons that are
great
ipa's that's the unfiltered whole so so
spell spell your name j-a-c-k-o-w-i-t-z
good enough that's that's correct and in
school yep
yes
jack-o'-lantern yep
jack-off tits
check it out wait we've heard too
are either of these acceptable according
to the seminar oh hell no dude you can't
say jack-o'-lantern you can't call a kid
that that's weird that's not you can't
call a kid anything you can't call him
by a hey what a jack-o'-lantern
just his name
no that's his name what was the biggest
takeaway from the seminar and this is
just general how to interact with
seven-year-old children
you know are you being taught at
seminars you get dinner every week
so it's a weekly sound the alarm yeah
it's a weekly seminar if he shows up
with a bruise like in good times
remember the little girl
had a burn on her back
uh raise the flag right that's a good
lesson okay and uh
so everybody has a flag he burped in my
face this afternoon apparently that's
within the confines he's allowed to do
that
okay okay
and you have to go okay fine yeah no
problem there you go all right closer
yeah uh in covert times
uh and i also got ejac
oh right ejac i still call him that
which i don't see i never saw as
ejaculation but we didn't mean either
well we did a show once with seth green
and and you were like hey jack and then
he came up to us and was like you really
call him ejac
oh i don't remember that
oh it's it's uh yeah but
you uh
did you ever complain to a teacher no no
what the [ __ ] what are you talking about
what do you [ __ ] complain about why
would you do that [ __ ] you know beat
the [ __ ] out of david simon and sith in
fifth grade yeah
that's my boy yeah i said don't ever
call me that name ever again you know
what that's that's what they used to say
about bully like if you fight if you
fight a bully they go away it's like
prison
punch the [ __ ]
yeah well no you yeah you've gotta you
know you gotta stop
the first day you gotta let people know
that you're ready to [ __ ] crazy
see that was my fault is that i i my
mistake was i was just bullied and then
i never did [ __ ] about it ever except
tell my parents who just went like hey
don come on
it'll be fine
you know and then my mom would go i'm
gonna call the principal and i go no
yeah actually there was a girl that
bullied me once because i had a unibrow
when i was really young and i had yeah i
know still yeah
lily's on the show
someone telling me yeah yeah
[Laughter]
but there is this girl named lea casa
grande who uh made fun of me she called
me a werewolf because of it and i told
him i can't i don't see it man yeah
right
what are you talking about
yeah and uh i told my dad and i said uh
yeah this girl lea casa grande she said
that i look like a werewolf and she said
well her last name is casa grande
so that means big house
and you need to say that she's going to
jail
let's go to the big house great father
wait a minute is your dad telling you
how to bag on a little girl yeah this is
my dad you're a [ __ ] please no no i
just translated her name bro yeah yeah
and then so i went up to her and said
hey by the way your name is casa grande
huh that means big she goes yeah i know
but not only were you not clever enough
to think of a joke you didn't even
repeat your dad's joke no no no it was
bad just completely froze translated her
name and she said i know she didn't know
what that meant and now
no bullying at all
no zero
no tolerance no no everyone is a nice
robot so what i say is how he's supposed
to know what's really wrong with you
[Laughter]
if [ __ ] kids aren't pointing it out
yeah thank god you you got to have a how
do you get uncle or a solid family
member
[ __ ] you go home
yeah
i think one of the reasons is a lot of
people have
thin skin today
is because of that you know because
everybody gets so offended and so hurt
man
you know we had these little kids around
you know doing a scene and and they're
all they look like they've all been
[ __ ] sedated oh and you're like hey
you guys are on a baseball team you know
hey and but they're just you know
because you don't keep score and
everybody's everyone's everybody gets a
[ __ ] trophy why don't you keep it
away
really because you don't want somebody
to but that's your generation
everybody's telling you generators oh no
you guys yeah you guys
yeah yeah i played sports but everything
was competitive i'm very competitive i
think it came from my childhood i think
i think it does i think it has to
inspire you to either right
want to be better or [ __ ] move on to
another sport yeah exactly i wanted
something wrong with eating [ __ ] and
being like god i suck at this yeah i'm
terrible at this all my teammates are
terrible
who are they protecting i don't
understand what the all right so
feelings so clearly as
as i look at the uh wolves of glendale
yeah what's up i see that you know
there's [ __ ] up when there's always
one [ __ ] good looking dude like an
almost famous right it's so true the
[ __ ] good-looking dude they put him
rather than cover the table
i don't know i just wanted the
out-of-focus guys in the background
these two guys are the silhouettes in
the back
but we have huge smiles on our faces
yeah
we didn't even know he could play music
when we picked him we just felt like oh
he's a good looking guy how did this
okay
um because he loves going to night clubs
with you guys bro because oh yeah he
looks better we're the best wing man
together yeah absolutely oh yeah and we
don't drink so we can drive it exactly
yeah
for today baby
that's right let's go damn right
yeah
so
are you from florida as well
new jersey born and raised all right and
you guys grew up together miami yes you
know each other all right so kit so i'm
a huge kiss man same so kiss put an ad
in there saying are you willing to do
anything to make it those guys are like
yeah so you got the two guys who are
jewish paul stanley said the jews and
then the drug addicts the jews are still
in the band and the drug addicts are out
but
they but they picked those dudes right
they picked the drummer that peter want
to play yep and they picked the the
[ __ ] space guy that had one red shoe
and an orange shoe yeah [ __ ] got high
crashes and they picked those dudes but
the four guys are more compelling than
the than the other guys but when you
have a problem in the band you have to
look at the band and say well we picked
this [ __ ] guy so right it's on us oh
absolutely
how did the whole idea of being a band
or doing music or and comedy and music
which is which is even better yeah wow i
don't even know where it is doctor do
you guys know who dr dementor is talked
about him today man actually we sold a
t-shirt to a woman who uh
she ordered a shirt and we were like oh
she lives here in glendale let's just
drive to her place yeah and she dropped
the shirt off she was a huge documentary
i don't think you're not going to be a
successful band in order to stay
together if if somebody buys your merch
maybe kiss you to deliver shirts
yeah so they probably did the houses and
they probably did that at the start it's
awesome
it's probably knocked on doors
so
you dropped it so so explain to me the
the the origins the origins though yeah
i can't speak for tom's origins you know
i'm sure he can do that himself but eric
and i
basically came up playing music together
in south florida and then in boston
in school
uh no just you know battle of the bands
well you were going to school did they
have music classes yeah like yeah
they would give an instrument a kid
would get an instrument and you have
your class that kind of thing right yeah
we yeah we were in band and stuff too
i was in i was in seventh grade in 1973.
all right so in seventh grade 74
when you went to junior high you saw
people walking home with like a flute
case or a trumpet
or a guitar or a bass however and in
three years
they would play in as ninth graders and
most of them were really [ __ ] good
yeah so they learned an instrument in
school right and guys played guitar and
people play bass and [ __ ] like drums and
they don't do that anymore yeah which i
think hurts uh of finding talented kids
because they would hand you an
instrument you could take it home you're
responsible for it gave you something to
do but also you could [ __ ] learn to
play something in three years yeah you
have so much energy too and that's not
uh they don't do that anymore and you
know it's funny
you would think that the kids because i
i worked at a junior high man and you
would think the kids that were in band
are the nerdy kids but that's true the
other part of you guys being the nerdy
kids you guys did the most drugs
yeah am i right or wrong
yeah because the guy the kids that we
would find with the heavy drugs all the
time were the little uh white kids from
los feliz you know what i mean yeah i
mean i got to find the old players
behind the bleachers i have all their
rights i can give you their number
i know a lot of little kids drug dealers
but um
no so eric and i were playing music
together we went to college together now
what kind of music rock music i'd say
mostly yeah but but everything like what
kind of [ __ ] rock we've got there
you're making me dig for the [ __ ]
show
we got to make you work
rock and roll rock and roll man
chuck berry
i mean we were in a band together in
college to kick some ass yeah i would
say it was like a foo fighters type
of thing hard rock hard rock uh rage
against machine inspiration how many
guys were in that
four five and what happened to the other
three guys dead they're all [ __ ] guys
they all got struck by one lightning
yeah uh no no one of them is the
producers longest music producer yes the
other produces our podcast yes talented
dude
um those are the core four yeah and yes
guys did the band break up or did you
guys just say yeah yeah yeah you guys
said
band broke up i wasn't anything you know
it was college everybody's doing
different things it's crazy uh but
anyways then we both moved to la around
the same time and we're just doing
comedy kind of randomly and you guys
came out here to be uh comedians or a
musician come on come out here to be a
session drummer okay to be a touring
drummer that's what i did for 10 years i
played with this guy nick waterhouse
for a while
you know nick waterhouse like you heard
nick waterhouse no man he's uh he's
awesome like that just said
absolutely
like pushing too hard and that kind of
stuff like old school rmb really fun
yeah kind of stuff
um yeah and what was he like as a as a
guy great guy
give us a little nick waterhouse
just like he's like a 60s cartoon
character
he dresses like it's so much he has like
the same outfit like 11 of the same
outfit but he's just like he's
incredibly smart gifted is he on the
spectrum dude no
i learned that because i have netflix
was he [ __ ] was he slow now is he a
spectrum yeah right
here honestly bro yeah you can look at
those tv shows oh yeah
that word is thrown around yeah the past
ten years yeah yeah then all of a sudden
now it's it's spectrum you know and if
it wasn't bad enough [ __ ] i think
hurts more than [ __ ] yeah yeah of
course it does yeah
that's a point
that cranks it up spazz yeah yeah that
doesn't feel like it's more so didn't
beyonce have to take back the lyric
spazz and her
albums yeah or we're taking those words
out or
i mean we'll take them off for you i
just feel like you know it regardless
ruin somebody's listening experience
because they're offended i mean beyonce
has so many millions and millions of
fans that it's like yeah change into
something else that also sounds cool and
whatever how they can do that now that's
what's really [ __ ] up actually is that
they're able to like oh we already
released this song but guess what you
can't listen to that anymore here's the
new version of the song yeah you know
it's really they're allowed to just
swipe it and replace it with something
that they think should be yeah unless
you bought the record i guess but who
has the record i don't know about
minecraft exactly yeah i mean they're
just kind of and even before you see a
show now they'll tell you that it has
strobe lights or it's right here yeah
yeah just yesterday i was watching the
things they're telling flashing lights
they're telling you what's going to
happen already right yeah instead of you
making the choice oh yeah strobe light
warning also the good guy's the bad guy
oh yeah so you know yeah and there's a
cameo i had no [ __ ] idea like my
first concert was actually kiss i was
like 10 years old my mom worked at a
radio station oh we got seventh row
center because no one picked up like the
the special tickets the contest what
year was that the 2000 oh that's when
they all got back together again yes it
was for the reunion tour and there was a
technology for him he did you shot the
[ __ ] arrow on his face yes when the
pigs had him you know exploding just get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah
my dad took me that show and he
purposely took me late as to not see ted
nugent and skid row
yeah that's like awesome alan jack with
stories oh yeah one interview yeah did
you say nazi uh yeah
[Laughter]
we actually got there at the wrong time
because he got there for the end of ted
nugent set and he gets there we both get
there and my dad's like all right it's
probably over and ted nugent goes who's
ready to eat some [ __ ] tonight and
everyone's like oh
like my dad's like oh yeah yeah okay and
then he like shot at bow and arrow on a
pig's head and it exploded and then kiss
went on no warnings no nothing wow i had
only read books at that time there was
no youtube or anything scared the [ __ ]
out of me just
oh god we were so close i was like i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here i left
after like four songs they were like my
favorite bands and flame cameras yeah
your favorite band scared you just get
the [ __ ] out of me
that scared you but you being seven and
hearing who's ready to eat some [ __ ]
didn't scare you
they're like seven feet tall in their in
their whole [ __ ] ghetto yes
yeah it was it was truly scary i think
it's a 10 year old you would be kind of
a little bit freaked out that was your
first concert too right first concert
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is scary mine was
matchbox 20 way more chill yeah right
right right that's matchbox 20. yeah
honest red hot chili peppers eighth
grade oh my god that's cool
you guys had such cooler ones which one
was yours
and chicano artists
real music new edition bro new edition
all right
uh you guys got together uh like not too
long or a few months ago right january
you guys got me right now
instagram like that oh i said oh these
dudes haven't posted that much oh
because
we just started yeah literally march we
came up with the name what's the secret
for you guys uh the longevity of you
guys staying together so long in our
brains yeah that's a good question
still together yeah thank you man
it's been an awesome ride
mine was kiss in uh 1970
uh i believe it was 76. out here and a
ticket at the forum five bucks you went
to the world yeah the forum was the
[ __ ] greatest place to see a show
every seat was great it wasn't a bad
seat oh yeah and it was fifteen dollars
yep and you would have thought i asked
my grandfather to buy me the [ __ ]
house next door to ours
it was like pulling [ __ ] impossible
those guys are like hey babe you're not
gonna pay for the ticket but we're gonna
give it away no no i'll get the money
[ __ ] fine [ __ ] bugs
[Laughter]
wow so you guys saw the same first no no
i saw my way but they were saying like
you guys yeah
together that long they were together
maybe
uh less than 10 years wow like to be
right and they started were they doing
the full kiss thing for me
they were like how sometimes like uh
chris rock on some pockets like
described martin lawrence as an opener
and he would like whoop everybody and
everyone would be nervous the headliners
would be nervous like when martin
lawrence was coming up but like kiss
used to do that show
and opening for like zeppelin and like
all these bigger bands and they would be
like oh [ __ ] they've got explosions
it doesn't matter anymore
yeah
yeah they didn't [ __ ] go easy on
anybody that was uh headlining they
[ __ ] went full on no yeah they went
hardcore we got to do that too we got to
really [ __ ] over these headlines yeah we
got to [ __ ] over the show yeah
you guys you guys
are you guys on stage together oh yeah
yeah doing stand-up no we're doing music
together because i asked grant i go do i
think i asked them like do you guys go
on stage together and and do your
stand-up so it's not not together
it is all together but we're performing
songs i play guitar tom plays keys drums
and we all sing yeah and you all do
stand up
and we we we do good in between songs
yeah and yes
how did you how did you guys put the set
list together because that's also a very
what you open with and yeah the banter
in between would you found there's like
a natural rhythm to some of the song we
only have six six and a half songs ready
to go yeah so we have a we feel like a
natural rhythm of what songs feel like
should fit where yes and we just kind of
talk through it there's six songs more
[ __ ] it's not like you were like oh
let's see yeah yeah yeah we also
improvised too yeah
hey where are you from all right let's
make a song out about nebraska let's go
write a song about a person from nova
scotia right right but we do a lot of
like workshopping like a stand-up like
around town 10-minute sets here there
right hey this opener did better at this
show let's not do the one that we've
been working on we'll get people on
board quicker yeah let's open this
where do you guys do that where can
people where do you guys go to do that
we play at the virgil a lot in silver
lake yeah we have a monthly show there
called the wolf den the virtual is where
it's circle lake on the santa monica
it's on santa monica yeah yeah
great great yeah great great bar so yeah
that's we got a monthly show there our
next one is september 10th i think but
there's little like pop-up shows and we
just did one in venice and yeah yeah if
anybody invites us we'll usually try to
make it work and go and play tennis
bring all our gear you know i like you
your music sounds like you're influenced
by by country music right because as
when i hear your lyrics it sounds like
when i hear country music you know
you're talking about like i woke up this
morning i got some coffee i hit my toe
oh my toe hurts then i went to get into
eggs oh i dropped the egg right there
it's really a lot of our songs are story
songs so we're telling a story start to
finish and it's from like a first person
perspective and country does that a ton
right that's why i think people love
country so much because it's kind of a
universal yes i can relate to this
person easy to follow yeah
yeah there's no bells and whistles man
it's just look this is what happened i
woke up
singing jokes if people aren't getting
it crystal clear right you're [ __ ]
yeah you know then they're lost and now
who knows if we're to get them back what
do they respond to first the the hook of
the song like the reading of the music
the music's definitely a cheap code
they're you know we start playing a tune
and people are attentive yeah um but
that's only because and these guys are
much better musicians than i am but
we're all professionally trained
musicians so we'll start playing a tune
and everybody's like hold on immediately
they're like oh this is an actual band
and we get to the first you can we i
don't want to speak for you guys but i
feel like first verse of our first song
people are like what the [ __ ] is going
on here right then the chorus hits which
is usually when the joke the first heavy
joke lands after the first chorus
everyone's generally on board it is sort
of like a kiss move because we play a
lot of shows with just stand ups and
then it's like okay one guy with a
microphone one guy with a microphone
yeah another person with a microphone
and then three dudes with instruments
singing in harmonies yeah right it's
like whoa it's a lot already this is
well yeah
it would uh for me as a stand-up there's
a certain vibe that that comes with
being a stand-up so i can see you guys
doing that and the guy is up next
probably talking [ __ ] right i'm sorry i
don't have a guitar right that's very
common
yeah that would be my survival mode man
yeah of course people would expect and i
don't [ __ ] have you know whatever i
got to see i've been trying to survive
man yeah but however there's always you
know if there's a comedian with a guitar
or someone shows up with a guitar i feel
like the initial reaction is oh boy
you guys i would say eight that horatio
sans finger bagged me
and that would
so your parents don't care that you guys
are throwing your [ __ ] lives away
oh they love it say anything they love
it they want you to do what did they
want you to do my parents as i feel like
all of our parents were from what i
understand we're very supportive there's
always one dude before
well i assume it's the same
irresponsibly supportive there's no
reason they should have said yeah go
play music your whole life yeah i wish
there was a support group for children
of over supportive parents like i would
have to go to it wow
be hard-pressed to find anybody out here
oh yeah i know well it would be no it
was literally like hey uh can i drive
you to your gig before like two hours
before i'll help you load your drums and
it's like you don't see my friend's
guitar player's mom bringing his [ __ ]
hand like dude my mom rented at one
point she
she wanted to for us to win a battle of
the bands and so she got she went around
to everybody that was planning to come
and got five dollars from each of them
to rent a bus so that they all had a
ride and i was on that bus as a fan of
his band in middle school oh [ __ ] yeah
cannot relate to this [ __ ] of course
healthily mental mentally stable [ __ ]
yeah we're trying to be honest with you
we're not trying to appear hard this is
the truth
yeah she's a freak though my mom's a
friend but that is
she like painted on the side of her van
like the name of the band and stuff for
just more exposure i guess she was yeah
i'm telling you overly but that also
gives us a lot of pressure what about
when kids saw you with the painted
[ __ ] side did you duck down or were
you proud of it i was proud of it
because i loved the band i loved what
you dug down if people saw it they read
your card and you're like
i dug down when they used to drop me off
in school bro you know what i mean yeah
no it got there though we got to when i
got older i started to actually realize
you know like oh this actually is not
cool that my mom is like talking to the
boys
14 15 going to clubs and
you know kind of translating between the
booking person and my mom and then being
like something's wrong here i
should probably just talk to this person
are you on stage rocking now i'm go
what's up everybody what's up just want
to give it up to my mom
everyone goes
love you son
that's my boy [ __ ] energy drink
you're sweating a lot yeah
but that's awesome man you guys don't
live together like the monkeys are that
[ __ ] no we live close though we look
close yeah we're about five minutes from
each other and eric's not far from here
yeah yeah we live in glendale man i
thought i asked him he was armenian you
know yeah right yeah
we don't have any armenian songs no he's
not argentine oh yes he says and i'm
russian yeah you're i'm a irish and
italian yeah yeah but uh but there are
plenty of there's italian brothers
where's it there's plenty of armenians
in glendale though that's not that it's
no myth that's for
sure for you
i love them how did that happen they're
always nice to me i i don't i i don't
know when i was a youngster man i guess
uh that's where they first started like
landing you know yeah and then it just
became a whole city man
it's true if you go to [ __ ] glendale
or where where they live and you come to
a rolling stop at an intersection
they will [ __ ]
light you up
the police over there are so yeah
right yes yes you've never gotten more
parking tickets they're on they're on
[ __ ]
you know that's the number one drive
yeah yeah number one city for for uh car
accidents oh really in the country that
makes sense are you serious yeah but
i'll tell you what i'm a country bro
whoa but you know why because it's no
accident you know what i mean right
okay
they're hard and so are we hard as [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
look at us yeah look our heart is fine
what about uh we're ready to fight and
what about uh do you think that uh
there's a place for
a relationship in a band
relationship was there a yoko ono in the
group or do you guys have a yoko or is
it easy to be with somebody
no because women they're trying to
[ __ ] settle down and stuff right
absolutely i have a fiance yeah yeah
ethan just got you she's cool she's the
coolest elise is the [ __ ] cool she's
the best i'm gonna start crying
george lopez
at a show actually she was hosting a
show
a comedy show and eric and i were in
another comedy band before this and we
got booked on the show and i was at the
time depressed and not looking for
anyone because i didn't think i deserved
anybody's company and i just thought she
was the sweetest human that's what a
[ __ ] real musician would say
yeah i was i was a real musician for
about six months
yeah i was about to jump
[Applause]
she was just a very instantaneously you
could tell she's like very decent human
being cared about other people and i
felt like that was very rare and that
and then i realized she's actually super
brilliant and funny much funnier than me
is she a comedian yeah she's a writer
but she also performs sometimes and
she's just uh i mean these guys know
football fans
this first sunday of the nfl season is
here and draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl
is giving new customers a can't miss
offer to celebrate the return of the nfl
season
right now
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly and as an added bonus for week
one
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion
it's simple
bet on an nfl team to win
if your team leads by 10 at any point
during the game you get paid
instantly
even if your team loses what makes
draftkings so great is everybody watches
football but when you got a little skin
in the game it makes the game even more
exciting and then you can uh
write to your friends about what your
record is what your wins are and i just
ran into a guy that was a draftkings guy
and he said those guys want me to give
my picks to them for free he said no way
so you got draftkings so draftkings
makes your
football game watching experience
uh much better and much richer for you
taking uh part in it
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use the promo code omghi to get
200 and free bets instantly when you
place a five dollar bet this sunday
that's code omghi only at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details
but she it helps that she's a writer i
mean it has to be some you can't have
two people one is uh in one business and
then one isn't completely detached from
anything involving the other right right
no she totally gets it and wants you
know she's on a trajectory of her own
just like you are and it's like it's
very supportive yeah very helpful very
supportive
does she want to join the band
uh she
she shows up to every rehearsal yeah she
always brings a different interim
[Laughter]
damn right
uh hopefully in the fall of next year
that's the plan but we'll see we're not
uh in a rush either so are we here or
will it be a destination i think it's
going to be here don't rush it bro to
take your time be like the raiders man
say next year is our year next year is
our year yeah i'm a knicks fan no i'm
not yeah next year's our near our year
uh did you get married here did you get
married somewhere else you have advice
he smashes
him what he's asking like what what what
should i do but i think nobody no no bro
i think you could tell him what not to
do
it sounds like from from what we were
talking about off pod a good piece of
advice i learned is not to keep a
shotgun in the bathroom it sounded like
that dude yeah there was a dude that uh
yeah i was saying that a guy uh
i think he was more i think they were
either gonna have sex or not have sex
with the dog was there and he shot
through the he shot through the door to
try to shoot the dog because he felt his
life was in danger hit his girlfriend
and killed her and he's doing life but
he was like i wasn't for my life right
right so that's something i'm just going
to take with me oh my god
i'm going to keep my shotgun uh on the
other it's the end of a country song
where the guy is really that's where he
is don't go by me ends in that killed
the girl
and he's doing live
god i got okay
that does sound like one of ours do you
have any advice no one piece of advice
oh please
i was married uh i was my boy's mom for
26 years man we we we
covet obviously like you guys know 50
like the the the divorce went through
the roof and obviously i was one of the
casualties but
i can tell you this even after 26 years
yeah bro it was just it's you know it
was it was a catalyst uh it was we
already you know a marriage already has
issues right but then but then you put
in the covid you put in finance you put
all this other [ __ ] to the pot man and
it was just it was just it you know it
couldn't could i couldn't i couldn't
hold it together but but i can tell you
this bro
you you have to listen quickly
everyone's got issues here's mine
absolutely bro but for you
you know you have to listen man cause
you're gonna you know one thing is this
listening i if i could tell you anything
is listening bro i mean it sounds simple
and it sounds very simplistic but it is
he's like yeah it's true that would help
i was a terrible listener bro i had no
patience and i and you seem like a cat
but there are two things not one
what's that
i have no patience is is yeah but
different than i'm not i can't listen i
don't want to i'm not a good listener
aren't they one and the same i'll take
i'll take both pieces of advice uh i try
to listen i try to be paid i'm a pretty
laid back yeah you seem like you're very
close to your mom right and then so you
have a lot of that feminine energy oh
thank you so so no no you're pretty high
no no i'm graceful you're just like a
woman no
he is a big heart he's empathetic he's a
great listener and that's a great reason
thank you bro all right the question one
of the questions is this is for all we
don't have to have the answer
what do you think keeps
a sex life alive in a marriage
because you know tom it's one of the
things that goes
about getting married yeah
yeah guys aren't married
but what do you think what do we think
you're gonna take a wild guess
you've been around people that are
[ __ ] married yeah i've seen movies
i'll say this i think i mean not to harp
on the listening i think communication
is everything just be honest about how
again none of us are married i'd say
what keeps the sex life alive don't go
by my term relationship
don't go by me don't go by me
if i had to say if i'm married for
someone 10 10 years 20 years which is an
insane amount of time yeah just be
honest about how you're feeling and
really any situation this goes for a
great sex life this goes for even
like regular friendships how we're
feeling and that's honestly why you're
talking about long-term trajectory for
the band i do think that all of us are
very good not to go from sex life to our
relationship it's all related
it's all about communication really good
we have great sex together all the time
yeah that's what keeps a band alive
writing songs or jamming is happening a
band is like a marriage yeah exactly
man's like a marriage it's just
communication and listening is i think
what i would say yeah once that stops
man i i think that
it leads to uh things falling apart but
i mean that's yes yeah
if i could go back on anything for me it
was that that part of just okay let me
hear you out versus acting like i was
listening because
i would many times i would act like i
was listening but i'm always thinking
like man you know all right all right
get to the point or whatever right but
uh yeah you know what a musician told me
he was in that he was in a band in santa
esmerelda okay
and he told me make sure your dick gets
as hard for home games as away games oh
my god dude
that's a good thing because sometimes
you're on the road and you're banging
you get home and you can't get hard and
she's like what's the matter
i'm tired
what's the matter
that's amazing we're not feeling nine
[ __ ] guys
bumper sticker on my 2012 prius
but is that not is that not good advice
i mean that sounds like good advice
sound advice sound advice what is this
ted nugent yeah ted nugent he was the
musician
[Laughter]
probably just like again communicating
when you guys are apart saying like hey
i can't wait
yeah either phone sex or sending nude
photos or just saying like oh man when i
get home i can't wait to you know
do whatever right
you know having sex with you
i can't wait to have sex with you again
later when i get home i can't wait to do
whatever i can yeah i can't that sounds
so i can't wait to do whatever on you
hurry home i'm gonna do whatever all
over you yeah yeah in 10 hours yeah
that's very funny yeah it's it's a it's
it's quite a right i mean listen yeah
we're all we're all performers life uh
in that bubble is much different than
the than the la than the bubbles in real
life
yeah well actually i mean i'd love to
ask you this question as you get from
say our level which is
low crap to your level and on the rise
how much more intense did things get how
clouded was your was your brain and your
your stress level and with all the other
things in your life way more complicated
yeah absolutely yeah it's not it's never
it's never easy you know you go from
being a stand-up comedian to getting a
deal to do a thing and then probably the
the part of you know them coming to see
you and then writing the show yeah like
it's a lot of work it's like going to
war
and will you be around at the at the end
and uh you know so many comedians that
we know
get uh deals for shows and get to the
thing but to actually get on the air and
stay on the air is all right there's
literally like nine hoops to get the
show from every idea
to get it on the air and like you're
saying instead of like you know it's
very did you feel like you could
maintain the balance of your life or did
you feel sometimes like oh [ __ ] i'm
right i i need to i need to give all my
mental energy to this thing so i don't
[ __ ] it up and therefore the other
elements of my life sort of
well you know it fell by the way so you
balance family and career broken life
i lived up by the oakwood apartments in
a condo okay and then awanga and uh um
and then i would always go down and pay
the bill late the mortgage the rent for
the condo was always late the car
payment was always late and i would go
down there and pay in person because you
know you just you want them to get it
but it would be maybe 10 days late
and uh we never really had uh
much money like in maybe
30 40 000 in the mid 60s you know in the
early 90s you know around that area
that's all they went to pay bills and
then when you go
and
the show first started to happen i used
to go to the atm and that would say like
maybe you know twelve hundred dollars or
yeah seven hundred fifty dollars in the
checking this is the sitcom you're doing
yeah before the sitcom okay and then
i went to the bank of america across
from warner brothers is where i used to
bank and then warner brothers is across
the street and and early on after the
show was was on for a little while i
went to the same atm and pulled out some
money and in the in the balance it said
uh 1.7 million dollars
it's kind of
and and the family man did it did it
change it's very damaging did it change
that dynamic
from when you were making a little bit
of scratch to when you had the the the
million and the bank did it did did it
become a different situation at home in
the beginning you know it's new it's new
money so so you do it but then you know
you want to keep the show on the air you
want to keep your your your [ __ ] on the
air so i was there all the time and then
after a while
it really you don't really kind of worry
about that stuff you're just more
worried about the writing and the
keeping it on the thing and then
creating it you know
and that's the but but it it is uh it's
quite different man it it it's it's it's
very different did you step in [ __ ] like
did you when you got all that cash like
do a couple of things you're like well
that was stupid what was your first
crazy impulse purchase yeah i just like
got rid of 30 000 for no reason or were
you wise enough to avoid i'm in this
hotel with these five hookers right
why did i just buy this soccer team
i was playing golf um at lakeside and on
the between the tenth hole and the end
of the round i bought a bentley
[Laughter]
okay hold on i got questions when i went
home i was in the driveway the guy was
waiting for him
on your phone how did you call somebody
oh my god you said i'll take the [ __ ]
family
that's so where did you test drive it
did you know i mean i saw one and i'm
you know you know what i want that one
george that's a hell of another
i was standing in front of the improv
and tom arnold and roseanne drove up in
a black bentley and i'd never seen a
bentley before
but i mean it's a beautiful [ __ ] car
yeah beautiful and i saw the bee on the
thing right there yes and i said [ __ ] if
i ever make it man
i [ __ ] love to have a car like that
absolutely and
yeah yeah i mean you got the sitcom just
like so you were playing golf like a few
days after no was this was already on
for maybe a couple years you clocked it
in your head
no no no no i mean it was just an
impulsive like i'm now's the time i'm
gonna [ __ ] do this it's time for my
family i'm not making this shot in
enough
strokes
i thought you were saying you were gonna
put money on the hole no no no i just
bought it because i wanted one that's
awesome
but that's what a lot of pro golf
golfers do i just learned that they
just for fun if you like tiger woods or
filmmakers
they're like 30 grand a hole let's go
man jesus yeah there's a guy that uh
that i know that plays with michael
jordan he plays like in big gambling
games and in that guy's golf bag he'll
have a brown paper sack yeah with like
100 with about 100k oh yeah yeah why not
that's a little because when you pay
because those guys those guys instead of
competing that's a cash game that's
their comp competition right gamble yeah
they're not in the nba anymore so let me
write you a check right they're like
just gotta pay up after the game that's
probably some of the rush i guess it's
like to have just the money on hand like
let me see the money let me touch it oh
yeah well that's why i mean you know we
talk about kids it's like why those guys
are addicted to drugs or like a lot of
rock stars get addicted to drugs the
thrill of playing to
50 000 people can probably only be equal
to doing a bunch of coke or earning an
incredible amount of money or these
other things that like normal life just
doesn't work or if one of the dudes has
anxiety or or is a little bit timid or
some [ __ ] that you don't expect to go
from you know clubs to [ __ ] arenas
and tour on such a you know so many
shows that they did maybe one of the
dudes is just you know
you have to bring to and then drink
becomes more magnified drugs become more
what was it like for you because i'm
sure you've dealt with this a million
times and and sometimes i'll deal with
it just as far as we'll finish a show
and then it's like i need something to
do i got to go to a taco truck right now
restless or yeah i don't know
chocolate truck's probably the worst
version i guess is that the worst
version of the two buckets
i just did some crazy [ __ ] this guy's
like yeah i gotta get some tacos i just
played it
i got a taco i bought six tacos dude i
said [ __ ] it oh i'm [ __ ] crazy i
spent 16 dollars i'm [ __ ] i just
played in front of 25 people i need an
orange juice
that's me
uh have you ever had 10 tacos bro
yeah i know i mean it does it does kind
of it it kind of goes in
in kind of way but you know it's nothing
you expect nobody can expect to be
successful but there's nothing that you
expect to have happen
you're just kind of a little bit
surprised when it happened i mean right
you know now 20 years later i'm doing a
show at nbc with my daughter my real
daughter my and so so i mean i'm i'm
doing that again yeah so i mean you
wouldn't expect it to
twice is that a multicam like the first
show multi-cool awesome cool man yeah
great that's [ __ ] awesome i also
loved your late night show thank you the
lopez today there was a lot of music on
that show i was going to say that's what
i want to bring up you broke a lot of i
don't know if you broke a lot of bands
but like there were some awesome musical
performances what did you guys see i
mean i mean that was the thing that we
had a great musical booker yeah i think
justin bieber's first late night show
was my show tonight but then we did far
east movement
uh those guys had like a g6 like a g6
yeah like a g6 yeah that song is [ __ ]
huge bruno mars and we had a lot of and
even even more classic i had uh uh def
leppard on at ariel's speed wagon
yeah you got a great host of host of
bands and stuff yeah that was great
that's it and you know the one thing i
had is i had common i guess common play
played basketball in college and i had a
uh a hoop there
and he was playing uh kareem so
that's awesome so [ __ ] common and
makes like two and kareem misses the sky
hook and then he makes another one and
you can see kareem everybody in the
audience is like
oh
[ __ ]
this really is this really and then and
then it's just like a yeah
yeah yeah just like a reserve did a
skyhook it went in yeah but another one
now commons not a pro right right he
shot it missed it missed it yeah we made
like two more years were you a
basketball fan yeah oh yeah they just uh
lebron and demar derozan just played in
the drew league and it was a similar
thing where they're on the same team and
they're playing these guys that are not
pros and the game is like close and
everybody's going oh man i don't know
are they going to beat lebron like is he
he's going to come down here and they're
going to beat him and he's got the pros
that we're watching apparently we're
like no dude don't worry about this
they're pro athletes at any minute they
can just turn it on and it lights out
and then that's exactly what happened
towards the end of the game is just like
oh
that's why they're like super pros yeah
because you don't even realize that even
the worst [ __ ] dude on an nba team
because there's not that many players
then there's 12 right it's better than
anybody that yeah
and they have to play against the best
players in the world constantly yeah all
the time yeah yeah that's all you guys
like basketball i love basketball yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah tom tom not so much but not really
we're gonna trade him up uh but eric and
i used to play all the time and then
like we've seen now playing pick up a
few injuries and that at least for me
has completely shifted my perspective i
love to watch but now it's all about
tennis i gotta be honest with you i've
switched to tennis
uh i can't i don't wanna i saw a guy
just a few months ago like fall on his
elbow and like the bone came out and i'm
just like and where are you
dude
in burbank dude
three on three no big deal you know it's
just like falling into the ground he
wasn't wearing the right shoes and yes
like he jumped on me just sort of like
slid right off of me and just like crack
and we're like
ambulance you know we're all just like i
don't want to play anymore that does
happen though i mean it does because you
know the guys aren't uh they don't
stretch or everything oh yeah
of course no but if it wasn't for
basketball for me as a kid yeah you know
like you i mean we had you guys
obviously different patterns of
different lives man you guys after
school you had after school program your
mom picked you up
did you guys out of high school they
took that away
yeah band practices man parking racks
for me and that's why i spent so many
years on the basketball court because it
was just and and you know my uh my
mentors were all uh uh street basketball
guys i don't know those are the guys
where'd you go
echo park silver lake oh wow and but it
wasn't what it is today bro you guys
they're all they're it's all you guys
now yeah of course yeah we moved from
new jersey
this is history sorry about that by the
way yourself hipsters no oh no lies
i've never met a hipster that doesn't
wear it you know what i mean like i
brought your hips right and they're like
no man oh damn i said but you're dressed
just like them no i know there's a
couple well you got to fit in man you
know we'll be bullied as adults and i
can't handle it this is gonna sound so
cocky what do you think of them as
hipsters jordan you can call us hipsters
i don't think so
jack knight r.i.p but he we did a show
with him and he called us echo park's
earth wind and fire
[Laughter]
but i think that like
hipsters i think douchey is a [ __ ]
term that you might have revealed
yourself sure yeah yeah that's for sure
i'll take that let's see what's going to
come at the end story here well i think
i think hipsters are pretending to be
cool
like to me like hipster is like a person
that is like trying to secure
a security guard yeah like a security
guard where you're trying to be
authoritative but you have no power
we are the guys in the band we do get
the fancy coffee like we do
these things yeah i don't think that i'm
cool but i see what you're i don't think
we're cool but i feel like one of the
least cool dudes in a circle at a bar in
silver lake yeah exactly if i go to a
bar what do you guys see when you go to
silver lake guys tattooed guys loose
scrolls oh yeah motorcycle yeah with a
motorcycle a triumph motorcycle full
sleeve tattoo a stupid leica camera and
just like the camera is cool and stupid
yeah they're somehow making like five
points amazing yeah they're making like
3.6 mil a year they're photographers
from photos yeah that's amazing they
almost all have one ear pierced there's
like a gold hoop uh or like a big
necklace or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
my son grew up in silver lake is that
what you see are they hipsters bro are
we silver misters beyonce
be honest
yeah if i saw you walking down the
street
damn it
i don't see it i don't know wow dude i
guess there's just there's to talk about
spectrum there's a spectrum of history
on the spectrum no you guys are blue
blue belts you're not black belts
silver lake and be like damn we are not
yes we're not black belts we're blue
belts
but you know david byrne from the
talking heads right yeah great [ __ ]
band great music he came out when he was
older and he's he's he has asperger's or
he's on the spectrum yeah so when you
see his his uh videos or his moves where
he's dancing awkward it's to him
and that was part of his
his on the spectrum his asperger's yeah
was the way that he moved and the things
that he wrote and the things that he did
yeah i mean you see it now because there
was no spectrum back when the talking
heads were doing it right right he just
wore a big suit and he had yeah weird
quirky moves but
all these names bro it's for all these
names right because i have three boys
bro and and i hear from all of them like
they all complained at me at one time or
another bro like one of them's like hey
daddy you know i have anger issues you
know i have depression and the other one
like oh i have shorts i have a short
attention right and i i'm showing you
know what i tell them i tell
[ __ ] i know you got all that
because i gave it to you because i have
it
that's a gift from me
just deal with it man you know
but you guys generation you guys you
guys have these things you guys have
trigger words do you guys have oh i just
came from therapy yeah you see what i'm
saying you know what i said bro i'm
talking trash i'm talking talking [ __ ]
about it but i i do agree that that that
it's healthy yeah having someone help
you and talking it's awesome well
especially if you want
balls that's my boy all my three boys
man how come the other two don't show up
just fade me yeah what the [ __ ]
no they don't talk to me they don't talk
to me bro
that makes sense but i think therapy i
think uh
yeah i think therapy is almost like uh
uh have you had it oh yeah i've been oh
22 years old oh okay
how did you april you gotta okay i know
the first time i went because i you know
we didn't grow up with that [ __ ] we
didn't grow up with it go to count it
was if our our especially for me man or
the people around me is if you went to
therapy it was almost an embarrassment
it was your weakness
you're [ __ ] crazy yeah and but so i
had a generational yeah generational
thing so i i know the first day i went
man i sat there pissed off and there's
the lady was just i felt like she was
talking at me which she wasn't it was
just my immaturity or not my inability
to understand you know
that someone's trying to help you
because of that home uh machoness you
know i was like [ __ ] this i shouldn't be
here you know [ __ ] you know i'm just
doing it for her
how was it that was my first day how was
your problem i was when you first went
bro [ __ ] brutal
because you know we weren't talking and
we're in the car not talking and then
you go upstairs you meet a new guy and
then you're sitting in there and
you're taking all this [ __ ] and then you
get back an [ __ ]
take [ __ ]
[Applause]
if a dude says the [ __ ] i think we're
held more accountable than one than a
woman
i think like if we like if you tell if
you tell the therapist what is what is
bothering you i think the woman takes it
more to heart
and doesn't forget it more than more
than a man would you know like if you
say something honest to a woman you
might be in the in the in the therapy
room
but when you get home
it'll [ __ ] linger it'll linger it'll
pop up yeah interesting okay
have you got you catch everything
they'll hold it against you
yeah and you're talking about couples
therapy specifically yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
how about you cats you guys ever i've
actually been to therapy with fabian all
right
that's why that's why
yeah yeah yeah i just started in july
just last month okay how was
this how was your first day your initial
day when you sit there and talk to a
perfect stranger because what i know
what they say what they say is
i'm not gonna give you answers i just
i'm here to to listen right yeah you
guys still first i would say i don't
know if you can speak to this first two
sessions was a lot of exposition just
like here's my she a lot about my dad
about my relationship with my parents
it's just it's always the death
there's your son right there we ruined
you we gotta find the trigger
you gotta find the trigger
that was
sessions it i feel
already more confident in my own skin
nice more so than i ever have in my
[ __ ] life
i wish that i did this four years ago i
feel great man and i i highly recommend
it but the first two sessions i was
nervous i was like my heart rate was up
i was like i gotta [ __ ] talk to a
stranger about yeah about parents and
real issues yeah but she's already like
asking me because i therapists my
therapist at least gives me things to
think about throughout the week and like
look at the world differently just a
single little question just a tool just
a tool they just give you tools to use
and it has really helped me already
what's your therapist name and address
yeah great what's your social security
number
if you saw your therapist getting coffee
you're not supposed to be developing
talking to us right uh yeah i saw my
therapist hitting golf balls at the
whitsett and i had to walk by like i
didn't know oh [ __ ] you just you ordered
a bentley instead yeah yeah i already
bought another brother i already had one
that was my second yeah
yeah no how was your session bro uh okay
my therapist is danny trejo and uh
[Laughter]
for a long time honestly i think it's a
good deal i was never really able to
afford good therapy i just you know
have like to drive up to the window let
me show you exactly
i'll have a number six like my dad yeah
no no no it's not that i just have
anxiety and a lot of stress about work
specifically which is why i wanted to
talk about this about this no no no okay
it's just about overwhelm and taking on
too much stress management but you know
what it's always overwhelming that's the
thing is that it never gets easier right
and i just want the tools to help uh not
be overwhelmed by all that [ __ ] yeah
that's george's advice
it's only get where it'll only get worse
you know the advice is the same or
they'll get one the advice is not all
the advice is go and do your best and
don't get high too high when it when
it's going good and don't get too low
and it's going back right right like
find a place in the middle i will still
operate you're very good at that
actually like there's been a few times
like we went to jfl a few years ago
you're gonna say went to jail i went to
jail uh when i was six no we were at we
were in canada playing comedy shows it's
a big festival and i was losing it a
little bit i was like super super
excited because i'd never seen you sound
like
you sound like no no no i don't like it
no no i'm saying this is a compliment
this is because i think that eric has a
good balance of like when to you know
because we all obviously help each other
out when we're low i think that's kind
of more just you know innate like oh
you're not feeling good let me help you
let's have fun together but it's rare
that somebody's too high or too excited
or two but i will tell you but i will
tell you this good at like hey calm down
i will tell you this if you want to
perform for a living and if you want to
do it
as your profession and if you want to do
it
for years
at some point
like in boxing you got to [ __ ] put
them up anxiety and [ __ ] depression
and issues aside
you're not going to get into a ring and
not have a fight it's a fight and at
some point you have to show somebody how
[ __ ] good you are regardless of what
[ __ ] issues you have you have nobody
gives a [ __ ] that to me is like the
professionalism where it's like you
don't have to put them up you're gonna
there's gonna be a time where you have
to you have to put them up right it's
like any you know a lot of people can be
funny the guy at your work is funny but
can you be funny tuesday in peoria at 6
00 p.m when you're not feeling like it
or if something bad happened in your
life that's right right now right
that's good advice bro it is
solid advice
because there's a joke where the boxers
are going to start boxing and you know
the guy is the thing and the guy in the
ring goes like this you know and the
other announcer goes what does that mean
he goes if he can't fight it don't mean
[ __ ]
be ready because that ain't going to
help you yeah yeah be always ready when
you when you go and do what you have to
do because it'll show
your own preparedness show yeah do you
have like a regiment to prepare yourself
for like an especially like if you're
doing a taping or something where that
you know there's a little more pressure
a little more quiet just a little more
quiet like like like even in this last
like we did the pilot
in april but you know i benefited from
being able to do it with the guy who was
my partner in the first show okay so
there was some familiarity not a new
person but doing the but when your
daughter's involved it's like now you
have you know extra you have to worry
about her i have to worry about myself
but i just wanted the show to get picked
up that was my wasn't worried about
finding a place on the air i was worried
about the first step not 10 steps down
the road i'm only worried about
the step that's in front of me not the
steps that are that are way ahead gotcha
and i just wanted to get the show picked
up if i said if i get it picked up then
we could put that behind us and now
we're into the second episode this is
the third episode
uh of the of the 12 and then you do the
fourth kind of hiatus but then my my
my goal would be
when september october comes is to get
the back nine
and finish the year and then the next
and then you get picked up for next year
and then the goals reshift again but i
don't look down the line i look at like
what's what's important that's right
you're present you're in the moment i
can only do the thing that's in front of
me not the things that are going to be
in front of me very wise yeah yeah i
like to have some soup that's kind of
mine generally just says soup yeah yeah
i like quiet time you know you gotta
have quality
i like that a lot how's your daughter
enjoying the experience so far i think
she's doing pretty good yeah you know
she has anxiety and all that that stuff
that but you know i don't i don't really
work with her as my daughter i kind of
let her do her thing i let the directors
talk to her and i let you know the
actors but i don't i don't you know i
don't treat her like like
you just say i don't have any advice for
you
you know i don't i don't overwhelm her
with things or or negative things like
sometimes i can say something in a way
that
would might trigger her to make it sound
like i'm negative right right right
right her experience at the end of the
day
so instead of like let's say we all five
we're doing a show
and if if you know willie was my son i'd
have to worry about him as my son and as
an actor and not just as an actor i
wouldn't have to worry about it right
right it's emotions but also i think i
think that's a smart move bro because
you keeping that distance from your
daughter in the professional setting
afterwards she's still your daughter
it's not like she's you know what i mean
i wouldn't want her to come to my room
and scream at me then you [ __ ] do it
then you're so [ __ ] good out here
right right right right right i don't
want that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i let the directors talk to her i let
you know people talk to her and not and
not me we kind of keep that do you talk
to the director to talk to her
yeah i know that was really good honey
fire my daughter
get her out of here
my daughter
if she wasn't good then we wouldn't got
picked up i would have taken the heat
yeah right yeah yeah yeah but you know
she was good enough obviously dna man
yeah he's your kid so obviously she's
gonna she's gonna have some of that um
it is kind of pretty [ __ ] amazing to
see
your kids it's your daughter oh my god
yeah you're blessed
man that'd be like watching my cat host
a late-night show
that's so cool watching swanson at the
[ __ ] hostess but uh talk about the
late night show we had
uh i mean matt if that show would have
continued it was two years if that would
have continued i would have [ __ ]
probably had diet you know yeah it's
like a [ __ ] night this is a sick
experiment what time john popper was a
blues traveler was on yeah they had a
green room in there drinking and he goes
shout out tequila george well yeah of
course man he's got all these [ __ ]
harmonicas here
i said are you the [ __ ] greatest
harmonica player in the world anywhere
like that he [ __ ] thought
hey we got so [ __ ] up
i drove up the hollywood bowl thinking
it was my street
whoa
yeah yeah yeah i lived off of nichols
canyon in franklin i [ __ ] went up the
hollywood ball i was like i'm almost
what the [ __ ]
i [ __ ] went up to hollywood i missed
it by about four miles yeah
are you drinking after the shows like
with this
with the with the guests
were you on autopilot at some time like
at that show because i feel like not
like you're telling the performance so
it seems like a lot of those shows are
like no no i was always i was into the
monologue into the interview into the
second interview but when i was done
talking we started [ __ ] drinking all
i had to do was introduce a band right
right yeah
you mean in between the shows you you
would start uh yeah oh right i thought
it was i thought it was when it was you
know
in the show
once the work part was over wow
yeah yeah that's good that makes sense
did you see a difference can you like
when you're watching the show can you
see okay here's what i wasn't drinking
and here's you i was starting no not
like that but you but i got called a
couple times ago were you yeah you said
yeah you were drunk last night during
the show what show was it
who was on yeah
were you how many days a week were you
taping at that point was it uh four
what's four days yeah see that's [ __ ]
wild that's like crazy you gotta make an
hour of television good television every
night yeah yeah yeah that's crazy yeah
and you're drinking most nights in
between
you know sometimes more than others but
yeah yeah uh depends on the guest or
depends on the band that depends on the
guest i think yeah yeah depending on i
guess yeah yeah and when we came in you
said you cranked it up to six times a
week now you're getting drunk
six times a week uh no i haven't drank
over there it's different now because
all
[Music]
[Applause]
the weight with the way that uh
with the way that things are run now
it's mostly it's definitely very
different from 20 years ago when i
started my first show
very very
antiseptic of things you can say and not
say of course
yeah yeah that makes sense probably like
wild west back one third of the things
you said to
on this wouldn't be allowed of course
not you know yeah no that's why i told
them not to release this yeah yeah i
said i can't say that you can't say this
hey where you been
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i
late
flagged on social media if you're using
uh puto reason now whoa really yeah it's
a salutation man nobody understands that
i got i got you know and they put you uh
yeah
you put your movement yeah yeah
it took you down for some shadow bands
wow it took me about like a month
and uh and [ __ ] and it wasn't even used
in a
derogatory way it was it was it was kind
of just in the comments terms of
endearment yeah but anyways man yeah so
the mexican soccer team
when they're gonna throw the ball oh
yeah the whole crowd yells
and he throws the ball
it's a [ __ ] legendary yeah so they
came to me and they said would you mind
recording a psa telling people in mexico
doctor i said you're out of your [ __ ]
mind absolutely no way
that's a fast track to get hated out of
you mexico not a champ death wish no
they try to do a thing where they tell
everybody like you know we're going to
stop the game if you're if you keep
yelling but who cares you know it's in
his words so crazy because i know i mean
we grew up in this town bro you grew up
i mean
i have a i've met a bunch of gay friends
man you know guys that i i grew up with
you don't even find out they were gay
two years later man
and you can still play around like that
with them what does that tell you about
your your your
ability to pull somebody that's a little
putigo you're like you're oblivious to
it yeah well he doesn't listen he said
that earlier
he doesn't know what they're talking
about maybe it was a different hug
here's a different hug that i didn't
know but uh no it it it uh when you wait
you haven't seen somebody on a long time
did they put their thumb in your ass
that happens
where did you go where how far how long
were you gone
well george man you you like i said you
grew up in this town you've had friends
that i'm sure bro you've had like uh
you're growing up
did you find out david david was gay
you know it's true yeah i mean right so
this is interesting that's it's a
different generation thing obviously for
you guys was that i feel like in
in recent years obviously it's become
more publicly acceptable to with the
pride movement and whatnot has become
like a much more wide scale universal
thing
how many
friends parents came out
as gay like
you know
more than two hands yeah after you know
the show glee came out of course
you think you think so yeah i mean will
and grace was huge
for for that kind of stuff and glee and
after that uh
ever all of my but
yeah no it's okay i would just say uh
generally generationally it's it's
obviously different for this is orange
ice cream because it's i want to try one
of those hello yes i actually would love
this if those are cold that's dope yeah
please
george lopez beer you're going to design
after the 50-50 first of all the ipa was
delicious
every flavor is delicious we all hear
the wolves of glendale drink it every
night
it's become a problem ah that's pretty
good
we're all addicted see you later
we're hooked on it no but i mean it it
is more of a of a situation now than
than when we were growing up i think i
think he called it
when you said it was it's a generational
thing yeah it was for us and you know
what bro now that i'm older and you're
wiser
and guys that i
knew like the guys that played football
right guys that came out
later and then you find out and i think
like wow man back in those days
they must have suffered
worse you know i mean they must have
said i can't imagine man
because there were guys that were dating
like a cheerleader and then you find out
years later oh that dude was gay yeah
like oh and then now as you you know
like i said older and wiser and you
think about you know how humans are
and you think wow man that that just you
know
back in those days a lot of those guys
got married oh he had kids just to show
they weren't gay yeah and uh and then
like wow like now your generation as
young as my son's generation you know if
you know
you're not they're not you guys are not
going to have to do that you got that
look i'm not going to get married and
have kids it's an amazing thing yeah
yeah i mean i mean you mean you can
adopt kids i mean sure i don't watch it
no no no yeah no i know you're saying
yeah it's just different there's nothing
right exactly bro and i do yeah man
you would ask me that 30 years ago i
would have been a [ __ ] [ __ ] about
it of course
you changed so much
[Laughter]
quack
[Laughter]
wisdom he was he was he was more of a
warrior like he was like you know he was
no no i'm back in that wagon
i've changed a lot
yeah you've changed in the last hour
louder than that yeah
you know i think maybe where you come
from uh like you know i didn't know my
father my grandparents raised me they
were older but i think there's some
dysfunction and some you know all of the
jagged [ __ ] edges you could have to
be so uncomfortable in your own [ __ ]
skin that would make you a better
performer than somebody
oh yeah that's a true wonderful [ __ ]
well that's why we need three of us
because none of us were treated like
utterances
there's a reason there's a reason why
third damage yeah there's a reason why
we would [ __ ] go on stage in front of
complete strangers to look for
acceptance right right right right if
everything was going right in our life
we wouldn't have the desire to seek
approval from strangers yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
bingo bingo george bye-bye you know what
i mean yeah and you and you love it yes
and that's why you know because when if
you think about like if you guys go and
you have a song and you start to you'll
think back and think like wow man like
was it
what was it like in the beginning
and
you treat almost everything kind of the
same you have to be prepared for every
show so as you rise yeah you're still
kind of doing the same thing it's just a
bit a bit of a change but it's not
drastic
where you know over the next night
kind of it kind of builds but i think
to add to that bro i think all of us as
human beings we all share this planet i
don't care if you're in africa or in
korea wherever it says i don't know
you know what i think i think we're all
damaged man i think everything
and i think there's good the more
someone tells more no no bro the more
someone tells me that they're they're uh
they're they're a perfect perfect person
with perfect parents the more [ __ ] up
i think they are i did a show man you
calling us liars no no no no no listen
bro back up i did a show uh uh i was i
did a show at the improv and it was me
the middle act the opener
and then the me in the middle like was
this girl man you know and we were
drinking we're all three drinking in the
hotel afterwards and the the opener kept
telling us of how i'm sorry i didn't
grow up like you guys i'm sorry i didn't
grow up like you guys i'm sorry right so
the and the chick was cool right uh uh
we're all uh we're uh smoking weed
drinking and we're being honest
and bro by the end by the time we got to
like four joints three four joints
[ __ ]
tequila
this guy was like man dude look at my
dad's a dick
i didn't want to you know i never got
along with him i was like and and and
it's and that and so i think as humans
man we all share this plan we all have
some [ __ ] to deal with and the more you
[ __ ] try to say it's you have a
perfect ride the more i think you might
be you know yeah what are you doing
you're trying to represent perfection
yeah which doesn't exist no it doesn't
exist so what do you say to somebody
that's out there that can't afford to
get to have therapy i mean you can look
online after i think you're right yeah
yeah
i mean there's people that struggle
every day that go to work i mean there's
more shootings now than there was when
we were like yeah like working this yeah
that's for sure no i just think as human
beings we've gotten lazy bro because
like you just said you said you could go
online now we could have gone online
back then remember we didn't have
[ __ ] the computers weren't even out
yet man and uh and so so today for
people to be stupid today
you're you're just a lazy [ __ ] because
you got you got libraries bro you got
libraries where the shit's free
do you know what i mean you can go and
log in with the library i agree with
this that will become the [ __ ] model
of this show if you're stupid today
you're lazy
dude you can learn you can go on youtube
you can spend you can spend two hours on
youtube you can learn whatever the [ __ ]
you want you can learn a second language
right i learned how to learn how to play
guitar youtube eric learned how to cook
a steak he's gonna teach me to cook he's
incredible you can learn whatever it
really is about laziness it's about
driving if you have ambition
turn it over [ __ ] what yeah
a little bit turn it over make sure it's
hot eventually tune in next week
add a little garlic and some olive oil
good luck turn it over once yeah but but
but it's true but it's it's at your it's
at your fingers learn whatever you want
yeah exactly it's crazy but also but
also let's say
social media
without bullying but social media and
the things that
people put up about themselves or women
that are almost [ __ ] naked or
forfeited soft porn bro
it's it's soft
social media is so important
because you know listen man and i hate
to sound like the two old deals here bro
but we bro for us we had magazines
we literally had we we literally i don't
know i'll tell you why our generation is
so creative man because we had to look
at one chick
pose like frozen
and in our minds we gotta make her move
i mean you guys actually get like a
little girl so i had to look at a
caveman woman
i started out with a [ __ ] smile
you're like is that a [ __ ] woman or
anything like that
that swan looks like a woman hold on but
it's true we jacked up
goddamn [ __ ] uh
yeah uh magazines magazines red red book
and all that [ __ ] yeah in the 70s people
were jacking off to photos of birds that
look like women yeah
yeah you know what's so funny that that
you know what's crazy about when you're
talking about the women on you you were
talking about the women on the social
media like for for years uh the women
are fighting not to be
uh objectified right
and then
you everybody left them alone a lot of
women right now i'm not saying all but
many women on social media
they were left alone but they
objectified themselves now do you know
like little did we know the secret was
just leave them alone i think they do
they really do i think i think they do
that everything is about you know how
they look or they took selfies or their
bodies and stuff like that yeah
it's more it's more easily accessible
than it's ever been before for everyone
and so there is that lane open for
women and for men to present themselves
and however they want and and there are
really like uh treating like a business
some people literally treat it like a
business
soft porn uh uh tag with business as a
co-owner of this business i do believe
that tom specifically should post a lot
more of you know shirtless uh videos and
stuff like that i just hold the camera
steady
started
sold 50 and carol you guys work at
caroline's yeah we're going to play
there uh
this week yeah we leave tomorrow morning
all right oh you guys are going to bear
caroline yeah well we're going to philly
first we're doing city winery uh
tomorrow we don't know what it is
on saturday we'll play city winery and
philly and then we're doing caroline's
wednesday the 31st yeah yeah [ __ ]
awesome yeah yeah we're psyched
make sure you get a new york dog in the
streets man yeah
okay we both lived there for a couple
years after all you lived there i lived
on columbus and 81st oh that was on 74th
and when did you live in new york back
when i was a young comic bro i lived
with a couple young
uh uh white kids would you live with you
little jewish kids brad trackman was
brad travis
but that sounds like a new york name
he's a good good good kid of course
great kids um it sounds like yeah but
that was that's where um that was the
only comment well i forget the other
cats but brad there was another cat
there was three of us uh um
but the other cat we never saw him
because he he wasn't a comic uh he was
working wall street so you never saw
that guy we never saw him you know yeah
yeah but but he said i'm getting married
but don't worry we're gonna hang out
but i worked out those i worked uh
cherry hill new jersey yeah
i don't know man it was my first two
three years of comedy man and wow and
that was you know i was like how did you
get do you take the train or or
train
greyhound
right now a ride
i you know we survived man i was barely
making any money longest you ever went
for a show at that point do you remember
was there a specifically tough
trip that you took just to go five
minutes ten minutes my my work i mean my
i mean what show you man no no the
longest you ever traveled to get to a
show even for like a day longest yeah
the longest trip
when i was a young cop yeah yeah young
young colleagues
you don't even think about yeah you're
not thinking about money man no i think
i think an artist and and george man let
me know
i think a lot of the cats that i came up
with i've been around 30 years bro i
made a fine career of it i've put my
kids to college put my wife to college
i've got i better you know like i've
said before bro like george i have
friends that up here and i have friends
that dropped off the wayside right but i
think the consistency of of loving the
craft all right obviously you're going
to love if the the millions come to you
like like what they did to george and
then they come right
but but i think what what consistency is
is just loving the craft yeah like be
true to yourself you know and a lot of
those cats that were just cha and we
knew a lot of these cats that were just
chasing the dream chasing the dream
right but then you see them on stage and
they were garbage man and one thing we
talked about last week man when i said
that's preparation
about preparation
by how diligent he was about putting
together his material yes and how hard
he worked away from the stage yeah we we
definitely get a rush from if we you
know we try out a new song and it goes
over really well or if we like really
crush at a show but you know we did a
studio session the other night where we
were there from like six to two in the
morning with our producer john speicher
shout out to him tom spiker i was i
called him today i was like that was so
[ __ ] fun
it was like summer
we're all like recording our songs and
there was no one watching and it was
like that could have been the reward
yeah you know and we have a lot of fun
doing the rehearsal like you said off
stage it's just fun right yeah that's
priority one great time and it's a lot
of the cats that that we came up with
who are a lot of them are gone bro you
know man
tons of these cats are gone they were
always like i want to be famous i want
to be famous
guess what you know yeah they're they're
out there you know nine to five or
somewhere of course and i always thought
uh was the cats that i loved which we
kind of liked the same cats the carlins
the lenny bruce's the priors they love
the craft man they love the the the the
enjoyment comes from creating something
out of nothing and it's your
something out of nothing not hearing it
you know not oh i'm going to use that
joke yeah you know what i mean so it's
yours that's why when i was listening to
you guys today i i thought these guys
are a little influenced by country music
a little bit that's why
you know which i i love you know i yeah
i love country bro you know especially
old country you give me johnny cash
campbell glenn campbell yeah
[ __ ] great
man
yeah great song yep guns and roses do it
in their in their set i know it's
awesome it's very cool what are your
favorite advances yeah what do you what
do you like to listen to when you're
jamming um
let's see santana all right
chicago but all my tastes are our older
music eagles sweetness
ccr yeah
i gotta recommend two things right off
the bat and i know eric's gonna back me
up on this huge
the eagles documentary have you seen
that alfredo's over here of course i
think that's what it is
yeah
yeah yeah that's unbelievable we love
that we've seen that several times and
then the santana what is it master class
yeah you watch that oh i love that
the actual master class sent it yeah i
think
it was equal parts awesome and hilarious
the way he's describing how he plays the
guitar it's like it's not helping me as
a guitarist at all learn how to play the
guitar yeah but it's super entertaining
why why do you say that what he would
say he would say you need to play inside
the note that's right yeah yeah what
does that mean it's just so deep that
you're like
i'm lost that's santana's take on how to
play the guitar and also like
professional musicians aren't using
master class so it's like my mother is
probably watching master class and so
it's like my mom watching santana going
play inside the note my mom going okay
interesting i never thought about it
like that yeah maybe so so i'm friends
with uh carlos santana oh my god uh-oh
and it's funny you speak of the master
class he's here and he said to this i
said this
hey how can i how can i take uh or where
do i sign up for that master class that
does
what he teaches
so
wait and you're listening to santana in
the background
he said yes he just said you need to get
in touch with adam and do a master class
on comedy the sixth sense that's
santana's answer to me like instead of
you you need to do a master class how do
i take your [ __ ] class he said you
need to do it you can't do it
i didn't ask how do i do a message i
said what's your login dude yeah give me
your info what's your password
my friends uh we've been friends a long
time that's awesome would you ever do
that i mean i know steve martin did the
master class i watched that yeah it was
pretty like good it was sort of useless
to like
to
it's i don't know stop editing yourself
bro
dude i love steve i don't want to say
it's useless but you know it was just
like you should move to new york or l.a
and uh yeah
back in the day
media wasn't around standing up is one
of the best books
incredible yeah he's a guy that uh that
was very very [ __ ] disconnected as a
person like uh away from the stage like
really very very kind of sad you hung
with him uh i saw i met him a couple
times very very awkward man around
people
i think he's married or been married a
couple times has kids i think which is
good i think i think those guys you know
some of them those guys older guys were
a little bit more
uncomfortable awkward
around people what about santana how is
he
yeah he's cool yeah
yeah i said to him what happened to the
sg from uh from woodstock he goes oh
yeah then you know back then we didn't
have a lot of money so
i couldn't get a guitar and someone was
broken so i broke it and then i bought
another one
i asked him what happened to it he said
you know they were they were just
starting so
if it wasn't broken they weren't going
to buy another one so he said he [ __ ]
smashed it awesome wow
he was in the arrows
you know i took drum lessons uh with his
wife with uh cindy blackman yeah yeah
yeah who are some of you who are some of
your favorite drummers
oh man i mean but she's she's amazing as
a drummer right she's ridiculous yeah
she's so good yeah yeah she plays in the
band now uh yeah yeah that's it because
dennis chambers was playing yeah with
another one yeah that's incredible i
think he got sick
i think so yeah yeah yeah and then cindy
came in and now she's had it for forever
yeah um my favorite drummers
i love john bonham
it's pretty hard to beat hard to beat
harder
quest love yeah i love a lot
uh
ringo ringo of course
josh freese is also amazing he plays in
uh right now he's playing with the
offspring what's the nine inch nails
there elon rubin yeah he's incredible
joy warren
yeah the the all the great guys are
great hal blaine i like a lot of the uh
wrecking crew guys like uh that's my
[ __ ]
is that the hardest thing to do man they
always say the hardest thing to do is to
be a drummer and sing
is that eric does it all the time
have you
they say that that's that's why there's
only one phil collins because the
hardest thing to do is well now there's
two yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the other african-american drummer with
uh
chester thompson and they they both
played
in sync
completely in sync insane
that's cool you said you saw that live
stream that's awesome yeah that's like
the album yes
that's so uh yeah so what's what's your
instrument bro piano you're a piano yeah
well tom also plays guitar in the band
he plays i play piano
because that's where everything starts
kind of in the yeah that's how it
started it was my first instrument that
i learned i self-taught on everything
but i started on piano i think piano is
the core of everything can somebody can
somebody self teach piano as easy as i
think on youtube yes and yeah
dude i taught every everything that i
learned i learned from youtube and i
worked at a piano bar in philadelphia in
2015 that's right you're the real piano
man
we've all put in ten thousand hours of
shitty coverage we've all played cover
gigs
i've used to play weddings bar mitzvahs
like one time i drove from l.a to el
paso
in one day to play a wedding and then
came back the next day
that's the old bruce lee quote man i
don't i don't fear the guy that
practices many uh kicks i i fear the guy
that practice one kick over and over man
yeah right yeah yeah that's the jazz
it's real that's real we played so many
shitty little gigs and uh we're lucky to
be able to do this now which is awesome
fun gigs thank you lord that's right
ultimately
um it should be it should be fun we
should always remember that
it shoots that's priority one yeah one
time i told the guy have fun and he
looked at me like [ __ ] you
that's so true man uh they're so and you
guys have met comedians because you're
traveling have you these cats who are
who who are
um
don't like what they do and you're like
and you're like why are you doing this
if you don't like it yeah what's the
[ __ ] point we'll do something else
life is short man yeah there's there's
been a couple people that you know were
yeah it was just sort of confusing and
those those are the first guys uh to
blame the audience why i showed them
hey bro how about you man you could have
turned it around at any time yeah of
course you know mm-hmm
almost immediately yeah well brian regan
the comedian says that
i love him i love brian
sweetheart man yeah a couple months ago
oh you're a sweet good dude incredible
so funny he was he was saying that
as the comedian you are the musician and
you're playing the audience
and sometimes you know they're a little
rusty or you but you got to get it
working to where
it's sounding good
in there and that's your job you know
that guy uh brian regan was one of the
one of the best comedians uh
structurally performance wise audience
reaction-wise and um i think he had a
deal to maybe do a television show
surprising that somebody that good
would not uh get an opportunity it's a
tough business
right that's how you look it's crazy and
and we kind of like some of the same
guys that have that really like um you
know where they write from from their
own yeah you know and i've always been a
big brian regan fan and and and uh
uh last year
uh i was at the uh uh
laugh actor in vegas and i didn't know
he was in the audience oh wow and this
is for me man you know there's guys that
we respect and i i respect the guy a lot
so i came off stage and then he went in
the dressing room and he was like dude
that's really good material and i said
you don't know what what that means to
me yeah come from you because i've
always and i told some of his bits you
know and he goes oh [ __ ] you know like
he doesn't customer but he said oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah but but no
yeah do you guys perform differently
knowing that there are
people in there that that you know
for me i got to stay the same i'm sure
you're the same way bro
right what do you guys think yeah i mean
yes
i assume you're bringing the hammer
either way yeah the thunder yeah
yeah at some point
yeah i did my hbo i did my specials
alive because i thought there wasn't
anything more um
frightening to a performer or like i
like boxing if you know you're gonna
fight right if you know you're going to
fight next july 4th weekend which is
sometimes the guys know a year ahead of
time that you start to train for that
day right it gives you a purpose instead
of saying oh i can do two shows and pull
the best from both shows
man i gotta tell you because i did
cheats i did do the two shows
they were like uh it started when you
guys were like 11 and 13 right when i
would drive i would drive around south
central looking for boxing gyms and i
would park the car yeah i'd get them out
and i would walk into gyms and i'd go
hey you guys guys got any kids their
size and then they would be like yeah we
got a little tyrone in jerome i said all
right let's go boom
we're like oh [ __ ] like oh
yeah all right
like oh come on
yeah
bruce lee chuck norris kareem
the sweet science bro it's called
science for a reason man it's really
people think that people think just two
people throwing hands um and there's you
know a little little movement here a
little movement there's the this is
there's a delicate dance there's like
rules to it same thing with like jazz
people think jazz is like oh it's
freeform you just play whatever it's
like no it has to swing there's a
vocabulary that you have to learn and
then you can play you got to create the
sandbox and then you can play in it you
know it's like yeah yeah yeah
walks inside the note you got to play
the playing side
inside the nose
that's why all great boxers are also
jazz musicians right that's true
i i i was at the hollywood bowl i think
i introduced santana to go into the
hollywood hall of fame wow my daughter
had a guitar we bought her a guitar and
uh i said ask carlos and and
and she said carlos like what advice
would you give me are trying to learn
she's like seven he goes well you just
play like really i love how you're
saying it sounds a lot like uh michael
jackson yeah
play at the strings if the strings were
attached from the guitar to your heart
right of course that's his masterclass
yeah yeah
what's a c chord do i start with bar
chords or whatever yeah should i run
scales
yeah but if you're just learning you're
like oh come on man just tell me how to
show me how to put my face how do i play
witchy woman yeah
yeah i was asking what amp to buy and
you told me you said play with your
heart
with my arms
but there is that uh
knowing the one you know the one or
whatever the one you know the one
whatever the one yeah the one getting
another one that's that's the that's the
thing the download i uh i got to play
with george clinton and parliament
funkadelic a few years ago it was
incredible badass bro that would you
guys play
we played flashlight
uh standing on the verge getting it on
uh give us a little flashlight
yeah you can feel it it's already in
there
yeah yeah
so that's the one that makes your head
move when you're driving exactly you
know
what's wrong
is rock on the one stone
i mean
rock is more two and four like
this is eric's master class
but that's uh you know yeah but that's
that's all part of it i mean it looks
like jazz but it's uh oh yeah there's
something to it there's also connections
why doesn't it all come from jazz bros
then they say it all comes from blues
all rock comes with rocks is that right
or wrong yeah is that a bad is that a
wrong statement i don't know
all rock comes from your heart
all rock is angst
rage
[Laughter]
glendale
but no it doesn't come all come from
blues and uh and and native american uh
yeah music did you see that documentary
rumble yeah so good
where the what's his name link ray he
made the secondly like the first like
rock song called the
it was in pulp fiction
oh right yes yes so it's awesome
but they also they always tell them
oh yeah oh yeah but that song there was
no lyrics to that song it was so badass
because he just turned his amp all the
way up all the distortion the song was
illegal
it was banned because it was it was too
salacious it was too awkward i would
make people do crazy things wow and that
was the invention of rock and roll
technically
i saw a documentary where they said well
they actually showed you and they and
then and they were showing the beats
from africa like years like yeah how
they how they're connected to all
today's music the beats the drums from
yeah of course
oh yeah
absolutely and if you want to see
anything good on youtube watch any
google any midnight specials because
they play live they didn't allow anybody
to go in there and play the track they
all played live everybody that sang yeah
everybody that performed
nobody could carry nobody yeah
that midnight special old gray whistle
test was also really good that was like
the best for i don't know i really geek
out on like late night performances yes
when i had my talk show there was a girl
early on that was a
uh a high ranking contestant on amer on
american idol i think and she
uh and her band played and i introduced
them from the back i would do the best
so i stood in the back
and and i watched and then the next day
i said hey man that [ __ ] girl sang
pretty good man that band sounded great
and they said the band played the track
and the singer sang the track
and i said what do you mean but the guy
was hitting the drugs and he's like no
they're muted mesh heads or something
yeah i was like what no it's how it goes
nobody played yeah oh [ __ ] hey you'll
never see that at a wolves of glendale
everybody again where you guys are going
to be and i'm going to put it on my
social media oh amazing that's awesome
city winery in philadelphia on the 20th
august 27th yeah and then august 31st
caroline's that's a wednesday night here
in l.a yeah september 10th at the virgin
olympics
and then other dates tbd follow us let's
see if uh we can't make it out there
september 10th grant yeah oh my god
sometimes come on neighborhood bro
years ago before you guys yeah of course
is it on sunset no no no no it's right
away right right right over the crosses
yeah there's already the t's where the
t's
there's a 7-eleven right there but i i i
mean i'm not even gonna mention
affiliations because
years have gone by i still i'm not going
to mention things like that yeah he did
it the other day uh when you said that
yeah
i saw a cholo out there in the parking
lot with an ep and i got out of my cargo
what's that for [ __ ] albus presley
yeah
[Laughter]
aaron the engineer we're gonna mute him
out so it's fine they're not going to
hear anything
oh yeah oh yeah thanks guys we look
forward to seeing you guys i have people
out there go see these guys they're
awesome thank you thank you george thank
you william appreciate you guys having
me
yeah much less success
thank you
one left that's one huh yeah oh man and
we got some beers through it this is
[ __ ]
toasted yeah nice nice and buzzy that's
great we also should mention we have a
podcast on this network
free network atc it's called success
express yeah it's one of the it's
probably the best show on the network
yeah it's it's definitely the best tied
with the dumbest uh so definitely check
that out if you [ __ ] care and [ __ ]
want to listen to it i guess yeah
success express right here on atc
you